so this is a video that went viral I got
14 million views in the last three days
okay did you see this archives yeah it's
a it's an interesting video okay this
show is basically like uh this is a
female gym influencer talking about
getting harassed at the gym coach girls
at the gym
I hate when they're sweaters to be so
uncomfortable
five pounds
the parents
excuse me you don't have to do that it's
okay no no it's okay I got it thank you
though
see what I mean
all right here we go
I just want to share my perspective on
this video if you guys want to watch the
full thing you can go over to her page
yo Mark I just want to let you know
you'll never look like that guy
that's what he really wanted to do with
this video he won his back oh Mark that
car looked like you that that's
literally what I look like dude no son
no look
that's me
look that's literally I think come on
bro is this part important
so she's basically saying this guy in
the corner of the gym is being a creep
and he keeps staring at her and then he
goes to try to help her put the 45 pound
dumbbell on and she is just like she has
a big caption like this is why I don't
want kids because men are awful or
whatever the [__] she says and then this
guy criticizes her being like he's
staring at you using machines that he
might need and then he goes to help you
like a nice person because putting a 45
pound I wouldn't really know but a 45
pound weight on a barbell is not [__]
easy off the ground so I'm trying to
help he's trying to help you out why are
you basically the internet is trashing
this girl oh they are they're trashing
oh okay I've seen a lot of these types
of videos though where like Shorty's
complain about that yeah there's like
another one that went viral yeah this is
the one I saw did you see this one like
we if anyone doesn't say we can play it
again stand up for myself
and revoke my membership
really
good
do you need something
do you need something right do you need
something
okay I thought so
what a [__]
[Music]
and when I stand up for myself so this
is another one super viral kind of the
same vibe
people are weighing in basically saying
like is this mistreatment are women
being unfairly harassed at the gym Etc
okay this is this is what I think is a
good skirt that's what I think is going
on do women get hit on the on it all the
[__] time is it annoying absolutely
I'm sure I think that
making a video of how you're getting hit
on at the gym became trendy and these
girls are hopping on a trend with
something that doesn't really justify
harassment but this is not like a unique
thing that they experience and they're
like let me just put this up to show
what my life is like it's literally them
going I could get some clout because
this is the new thing to show how
annoying guys are at the gym is like the
in this horrible comparison but like the
Aziz Ansari me too yeah yeah yeah
so that everybody hops on the phone
that's not a bad parallel actually and I
also I haven't seen the ones of people
being on I've only seen these two now
yeah where people are like that's not
what are you [__] talking about yeah
and it almost seems like the internet is
coming back remember when that street
harassment video came out like 10 years
ago where the girl was walking around
the city getting harassed by men and 90
of it was men just saying hi yeah which
I guess is trying to hit on you maybe
like inconvenience and harassment and
that that was sorry I interrupt you go
go do I guess just the the movement of
dissenting voice at the time felt much
scarier like there was no movement to be
like [__] people are saying hi get over
yourself and then that voice has gotten
louder over the past 10 years and now
when you try to do these that they're
like roaring at you like who the [__]
are you yeah nobody's hitting you I'm
sure you get hit on this ain't the time
stop shaming this guy making him a
pervert etc etc yeah I kind of think
there's a difference between the first
video and the second video
like the set the second video of the
girl seems like intentionally aggressive
like looking to pick a fight and looking
to like seem like a hero by making a
moment with this guy and I'm sure that
she's been like harassed in the gym
before I'm sure she's been hit on it's
super annoying like I don't discount
that at all I think it happens all the
time to a ton of women in the gym no
question the first girl though part of
me seems like there's like a I don't
know she seems like legitimately more
scared she seems scared and I'm like I
almost feel like there's something more
sad about it like not to [__] bring
the mood down but like she seems like
someone that's like been traumatized in
the past and like has had bad
experiences with guys and then is like
acting out of like fear and like a
trauma response and they're just making
that trauma responds on to a situation
that might not just exactly and then
making a video just glued into her own
little world being like this is
definitely what this was because she's
traumatized and then didn't realize that
now she's getting killed on the internet
so I'm like I almost feel bad for her
where I'm like I don't even think she
knew what she was doing I mean obviously
she's making content around it to be
like look at what a perfect this guy is
expecting everyone to validate her
because she's living in her own little
world because of the trauma she went
through it's my assessment maybe it's
both though like maybe both of them have
experienced like horrible [__] with
dudes to have that idea about them in
the first place because when you first
see a guy at the gym and your first
assessment of that person is that
they're trying to do something that is
maybe not only objectifying you but like
potentially putting you in a dangerous
situation you went through some [__]
up [__] with dudes yeah of course like
bad so maybe the other girl reacted way
more aggressive and that just might be
the way she responds yeah exactly where
this one responds more out of fear maybe
but there has to be like a trigger point
for both of them because this is
irrational Behavior that's the way I
look at I'm like no normal person even a
girl that gets hit on all the time at
the gym yeah isn't like I'm scared
you're standing near me get away from me
like that seems like irrational Behavior
due to some type of like maybe I gotta
watch the first one back because I
didn't really pick up on the fact that
she was scared I kind of saw like she
was just like oh I know he's gonna talk
to me or I know he's going to try to
talk to me I know he's going to try to
talk to me and so then when he finally
does she was just really quick to just
like no no know I'm not going to accept
any help because if I accept help then
it opens the door for you trying to talk
to me and that's the way I'm assuming
that that happened in the past and then
something horrible happened oh or like
or she just doesn't want attention when
she's totally but maybe like it happened
and then like a dude she was nice to a
guy and then he started pressing her and
then stalking her and then being like yo
why the [__] did you be nice to me if
you're not gonna give me some [__] what
the [__] is wrong with you so like
usually I think what you're basically
trying to say is there was like a
horrible experience that's created this
irrational behavior from both of them
but they're not acting like normal human
beings like this is not how you should
behave yeah or not how you should feel
in these moments yeah I just wish all
men knew like don't hit on girls in the
gym like they've been complaining about
this [__] forever it's like when you're
in the gym you're focused on
bettering yourself you're in a
vulnerable position sometimes it's like
I'm trying to lift weights yeah I'm
trying to have less clothes than I
usually have on and [__] like that just
just don't do it I never do it I never
well I still don't know
no no but I never did it because like I
don't like the idea of like hitting on
someone in a place where they can't
exactly leave when they want to yeah you
know it just feels like that like if
they're I've seen dudes hit on shorties
on a treadmill and it's like she's
running like she got two miles left can
you imagine known a girl that's doing
that [__] squat thing yeah I can go I
can't get up without pushing all like
I'm in a super vulnerable position yeah
yeah like you're spotting her you know
you want to go on a date yeah if you hit
on a girl at the mall
it's funny though because you hear some
girls
you know looking at all these [__]
workout accounts and [__] you hear some
girls say uh I don't mind if somebody
hits somebody in the gym if I give them
the tell first so what a lot of these
girls be like if I stare at him a bunch
of times and he knows that they're
exactly but it's interesting that a lot
of girls who are like real like gym
workout people that's like they're
basically part-time job they're spending
a lot of their free time at the gym
that's where they're going to meet
people and you're going to be attracted
to the good looking guy at the gym
because values the same [__] she values
and they're joining that gym like how it
was a Gym Bro culture like girls that do
care about their body like this have
been more into that free weights that
section of the the gym when we were
doing it when we were growing up bro
there so a guy's excuse would be like I
would do this with other dudes as well
we're helping we're spotting we're doing
this and that but then yeah
don't do it yeah yeah but well here's
the thing don't do it but if it's your
gym you're going to see this person over
and over again eventually you're gonna
talk to that person in an organic
it's just gonna happen like in the same
way if you play bass football at the
same court you're going to end up
talking to people
how about that say what don't be creepy
exactly yeah but Meathead dudes are Loki
also thinks something happens here at
the gym like you got [__]
testosterone like there's a reason why I
think guys do it so much at the gym is I
think something happens to a guy's
Brands were you just feeling good about
it I say you feel good about it is
amazing you feel sexual like you look
good yeah
Z sex hormone you took some pre-workout
yeah yeah yeah it literally subject yeah
yeah I also think the reaction is so
strong because as much as not as much
but women will get hit on when they
don't want to I think most guys have
been in a position where a girl like
thinks we're trying to hit on them or
we're not yeah you're like I'm just
being nice and then that is like first
video was yeah and then it I think guys
get super upset because it's like yo
you're just questioning my intentions as
if they're dishonorable like like that
then we get real like triggered and then
this is like perfect video where like
you know anybody that's operating in a
manosphere sees this and they're like
see yeah chances are instead of looking
at it in the way Mark was saying earlier
it's like yo maybe both these girls had
a [__] horrible like maybe violent
experience maybe I don't know I also
don't want to put that on every girl
that doesn't like it but what I'm what
we're basically saying is this is
irrational behavior in the same way you
see something like Karen on the street
isn't representative every single
[__] girl out there it's that's
irrational Behavior there's a difference
between irrational Behavior most girls
who watch this and be like okay it's
annoying getting hit on but these girls
are [__] crazy right but when this
justifies your fears about women this is
the first video You're gonna pop up like
see yeah I told you this is how they act
yeah yeah yeah
so look stronger at the gym ladies if
you don't want no spots no help look
stronger get on that trt get on them
peptides I just don't even talk to
anyone at the gym actually I'll talk to
you guys I don't know but these outfits
do girls wear to the gym are [__]
[__]
to make them look like uh let's also
talk about that that [__] is [__]
stupid bro and I understand it's like
the gym selfies you want to post it and
that kind of [__] like that but like
it's ridiculous speak for yourself it's
[__] ridiculous like
yeah you don't think it's ridiculous I
don't know the outfits I do think it's
funny when girls go like full hair and
makeup to the gym like to me I'm like
all right no no I mean if that's what
you want to do that's cool but then I'm
kind of like really the huge tread
knockout is that in like a just a normal
pair like bicycle shorts just like some
booty shorts they actually will cause
they will Stitch the back seam so it
pinches in so it actually makes you look
like you have a bubble ass yeah yeah
yeah it's wow The Tick Tock leggings
yeah the ones they have a lot of
patterns on it yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's stupid but yeah I don't mind a
decent Ambiance at the gym and so you
end up in a [__] video
don't talk to the girls yeah but then
you're just a you're staring no I don't
stare you can look without that girl you
the guy glanced over five times you
could be glancing at that bad ass five
times yeah I'll wear sunglasses you're
not a photographic member I also wearing
sunglasses a squat machine like he's
Stevie Wonder looking at ass I'll be
struggling because I go to the group
classes and [__] like that so I'll be
struggling like all the classes I've
been [__] hard yeah solid Court oh
[__] you do hot yoga too don't you
there's no mirror there though but solid
core that [__] is hard as [__] you ever
did that no it's like just Pilates on
steroids your heart or is hard yeah
great guys uh
I'm just curious damn
no you've done solid Court you've told
me about it no
crazy either for former Pilates
I've never done solid core bro no
any mark